speaking of resets you're from Illinois  right yes  Illinois's new safety act yeah okay  where where you can't even protect your  own property you know trespassers can  come in and camp on your property on  your front porch and the police will not  do anything yeah I mean what is going on  they're attacking property rights values  across the board in Illinois you will  owe nothing and you will be happy see  this is this is a good point the safety  act you heard about this  they're saying that as you said the  police won't respond to trespassers on  your property and they're going to  eliminate cash bail for most criminal  offenders murder even murder okay but  you guys realize you're talking to a guy  who's from California  you're you're like oh the good old days  don't let them do it to you but this is  another example you're talking this is  Chicago in the suburbs  dictating to the rest of the state